we're learning new details this morning
about the high school teacher who
stopped a student gunman in Illinois
witnesses say veteran Matt and PE
teacher Angela McQueen grabbed the
shooters arm and subdued him it happened
Wednesday at Mattoon high school one
student was wounded and later released
from the hospital the teacher was
unarmed the suspect who is a minor is
charged with aggravated battery with a
firearm turned to KOCO is outside the
Mattoon Police Department in Illinois
Tony good morning good morning
investigators here are working their way
through about 200 interviews they're
hoping to find out the gunman's motive
and how he obtained his weapon but at
the same time they're already pointing
to this incident as an example of the
value of preparing teachers to respond
to active shooters even though we're all
probably scared to come back we we need
other students to make sure that they're
comfortable Jenni Hudspeth and friends
spent Thursday decorating Mattoon high
school to comfort classmates who fled
the shooting in terror and to honor
Angela McQueen a teacher now being
hailed as their hero McQueen and
hundreds of students were in the school
cafeteria Wednesday when a student
opened fire the bullets basically
shattering in one of the pillars in the
middle of the cafeteria one student was
struck in the hand and chest
he's now in good condition his mother
posting on Facebook we are very blessed
it's not worse she described McQueen
lunging for the shooters arm forcing it
upward he fired five or six more rounds
into the ceiling as she took him down
when she saw the situation and you know
okay this kid's gonna kill somebody if I
don't do something so she just took
action but Barbara McQueen is Angela's
mother I don't think she even gave it a
thought
because when she saw the gun I'm sure it
was just like oh my goodness we're not
gonna have another Sandy Hook she just
reacted instinctively McQueen was a high
school
basketball star a power forward who
followed her parents into teaching
she's been at Mattoon now for 17 years
mrs. McQueen is Chuck Norris basically
pretty much stumbling that she's a hero
- Angela McQueen's mother told us her
daughter has not yet ready to speak on
camera the police chief here said that
Mattoon high school recently underwent
active shooter training in that training
confrontation is considered a strategy
of last resort but if it's needed the
goal should be to disrupt the shooters
ability to aim according to witnesses
that is exactly what Angela McQueen did
viana Chuck Norris take note this is no
Queens in town like Sabo no but if you
asked her guys does she feel like a hero
she would say nope exactly I just did
what I had to do sure her mother is
proud morning